the tennis's last steps on Guatemalan
soil and she's feeling good she's one of
a group of 18 Venezuelans who are trying
to get to the U.S
just a quick River Crossing and they're
at the last country in the way Mexico
the raft might be rickety but the calm
Waters of the suchiati are nothing
compared to what they've been through
the treacherous Jungle of the durian Gap
and several countries after that but now
they're here
we feel relieved because it's been such
a long journey and now we are close just
one more country and then we're at the
U.S but what they see is the last step
in their Odyssey might be the hardest
part Mexico's full right now the
government says that 6 000 people are
crossing this border every day and that
they're overwhelmed they're trying to
relieve congestion by bussing people up
the country away from the border an
impromptu Camp has appeared on the
suchiati bank while people wait for
their turn but some here tell Genesis
that's taken over a week
the group has to decide
if we stay here we have no money no food
so no I have three children or better to
go on
and so begins a 30 kilometer walk to the
nearest city tapachula
[Music]
tapachula a migrant Hub is in an
emergency situation too the head of
Mexico's Refugee agency told me
we are seeing record numbers we've never
seen The Surge we've had this year
especially in the last two months
particularly September
now Mexico is exploring the possibility
of deporting people from South America
including Venezuelans back home and the
seasonal group don't know that yet they
hit a migration checkpoint
do you know the risks you're running
taking the children by the side of the
motorway
but the order seems to be to let them go
on for now
there's still kilometers from tapachula
I asked kennesis what they're fleeing
in Venezuela the money isn't enough for
food work doesn't pay the government is
bad you can't live right now
seven million Venezuelans have left the
country in recent years they're a big
part of this together with Haitians
nicaraguans Cubans ecuadorians and
others
a surge that U.S and Mexican authorities
are struggling to cope with as more and
more people arrive John Holman Al jazira
the suchiati river
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera